et
[Musique]
pour se débarrasser de leurs prisonniers
les gibiers ont transformé les chats de
confiture on joue on va l'épier les
autres au jeu de la petite boîte ont été
changés en n'importe quoi et bien direz
vous les shadoks voulait vivre sur la
terre
ils ont ce qu'ils voulaient oui il sur
ce qu'ils voulaient et pendant très
longtemps
ils vécurent comme ça on en trouve
encore des quantités de nos jours des
shadoks prisonnier de ce temps là
malheureusement on ne les voit pas mais
ils sont la transformer en arbre en
cailloux ou objets ménagers apparemment
innocent apparemment seulement parce que
méfiez vous c'est shadoks là ont gardé
au plus profond de leur coeur une soif
de vengeance qui ne s'était rétracté
mais maintenant ils n'ont plus 2 et gêne
évidemment ou de gy be sure qui se
venger mais ça ne fait rien parce que
tout ce qui bouge maintenant sur la
terre pour eux c'est du jet de celle qui
vous tombe sur la tête exprès parce que
vous passez dessous pouvez être sûr que
c'est une échelle shadoks
le caillou qui dépasse le bec de gascon
n'a pas vu tout ça aussi c'est les
shadoks
et quand vous roulez en auto à une
allure normale et que tout d'un coup
sans prévenir un platane la route c'est
pas par hasard c'est un platane shadow
crise a fait exprès à terre donc en
était pleine mais la lune elles en
étaient vides ou presque
il en était tellement descendu du chat
d'oc note sur la terre il en était
tellement jamais revu
on en avait tellement ton voilier est
renvoyée encore pour aller voir si les
autres avait gagné il y en avait eu
tellement plus de ça qui prenons tous
sont là des péripéties et quasiment
autant le faire exprès que des shadoks
sur la lune il n'y en avait plus
ah si il restait quand même trois
responsables est un imbécile alors
peut-être que ça allait reprendre
mais vous savez on sait jamais
[Musique]
et